à l'hôtel queen elizabeth revenus de
services ça donne ok vous avez les mains
propres
oui vous fumez bon je rappelle le
règlement intérieur
on ne fume pas on ne dit pas de gros
mots on ne touche pas à la vitre si on
ne peut pas on ne vous voit et on veut
parler correctement d'accord mairie des
lilas ouais ça roule pas hyper bien mais
je connais pas je serai ça dépend
répondu vous voulez mettre et détenir 4
je parle en argent 1 pourquoi je peux
vous faire une course spéciale ne n'ont
pas une minute avant que voilà dix
minutes sur le trottoir et ses 500
balles j'ai deux belges
je veux te tarifs belge alors il ya de
talent il ya pour les belges ou et n'ont
fait ça depuis deux trois mois
maintenant et pourquoi
mais parce que comme ça on peut faire
plus d'argent parce qu'il regarde pas le
compteur et en général on double le
tarif le belge sait quoi république
c'est une avenue pas deuxième cliente
la première a éclaté en sanglots au
total à ce qu'on a mis deux heures pour
aller à
un kilomètre et a commencé à me casser
les couilles et puis j'aime pas beaucoup
d'aliments jetés dans la gueule à la mal
pris webb a commencé à faire de la
section j'ai mis une claque dans la
gueule avec des datations ni plus ni
moins 7 pouces ya ce bon alors on va
avec je sais on va passer par créteil va
pas recréer oui là on va chercher mon
beau frère il connaît hyper bien paris
et on va même était pas que je suis
président j'ai pas vous mettre quelque
part je vais déposer quelque part attend
les jo di rosa mais vous allez où
mais c'est en japonais s'adresse à un
autre plan c'est pas un truc en français
un plan en français non sens japonais ça
je dis pas japonais moi on va faire un
essai déjà sept points bruilhois par un
essai de décharges électriques là ce que
j'arrive pas à régler mon truc
anti-agression c'est du triphasé vous
allez prendre du 220 volts pas une
seconde je te prête voulait serrer un
mouchoir un truc certes un petit peu mal
c'est dur de seconde à adidogomé sexe à
grande échelle obligé moi j'ai mon truc
qui meurent si vous m'avez sait on a
ok bon bah c'est bon ouais bah occasion
près du parc montsouris ondima sont
riches et féminins ont dit pas mon
souhait c'est humiliant vous êtes une
faute de français là tout à l'heure une
faute de goût maintenant une faute de
français ça ça fait deux fautes en dix
mois sourit non ma souris ces famines et
ben le par il s'appelle montsouris parce
que c'est un mémo à noter le courant
rétabli sur simplement à cette heure là
j'essaie de vous
j'ai fini mon service dans ce que je
vous demande et parce que j'ai pas vous
chargez c'est de vous coucher faut pas
qu'on vous voit aller se coucher vous si
jamais je me peux gaulle et la cie
retraite dix ans encore vraiment
vraiment au corps voilà vous êtes à
l'aise la bombe ou je vais vous appelez
sultan et vous je vous appelez vie qui
comme ça si jamais on a un contrôle
safra genre couple de belges allemands
tuent le temps pas bouger tant manger
une uns voulaient pister à vendre et je
me sente avant de voir si c'est loin
non ça va aller pas bougé un bon donne
la patte le temps de la pâte à sel bien
au pays à des chocolats poursuit le
temps il veut un chocolat au pays c'est
que c'est du sucre 1 er mai l'acteur
mois plus d'un règlement intérieur à mon
coup de main pour parler poliment petits
chéris
ma propre est correct ok ok ma grosse on
va y aller
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux